et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
agnèse bonjour merci beaucoup d'être là
ministre de la transition énergétique on
va bien sûr longuement parler dans
quelques instants du projet de loi
développement des énergies renouvelables
un tout petit peu retardé au Sénat qui
débutera aujourd'hui mais d'abord un mot
sur les la crise des carburants puisque
la grève a été levée on l'a appris hier
à la raffinerie totale de Gonfreville
combien de stations services sont encore
en difficulté ce matin alors sur les
stations-service on a au plan national
une situation qui est
à peu près revenu à la normale dans
beaucoup de régions
trois régions qui sont encore en
difficulté l'Île-de-France qui est
notamment alimenté par contreville sur
l'essence donc c'est un sujet qui
concerne essentiellement les sens et
plutôt les petites stations qui ont plus
de difficultés à acheminer des stocks de
carburant Bourgogne Franche-Comté et
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes parce que à Feyzin
il y a encore un mouvement alors
certains car d'équipe fonctionne
d'autres il y a des grévistes donc la
situation est en train de se normaliser
mais effectivement des tensions plus
particulièrement sur l'Île-de-France et
sur Auvergne Rhône-Alpes et franchement
vous avez des chiffres précis ou c'est
compliqué en fait les chiffres la
qualité des chiffres dans une situation
où on est plus en mode crise et moins
bonne parce que les déclarations de se
font pas en temps réel et c'est pour ça
que je veux pas affirmer des chiffres
qui ne seraient pas ce qu'on sait c'est
que grosso modo là où on était au delà
de 10% en plan national on est en
dessous et que on a une nette différence
entre l'île de France et dans un
deuxième niveau Auvergne Rhône-Alpes et
Bourgogne franchement vous espérons
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui les
distributeurs et les stations services
nous disent il va avoir une nette
amélioration c'est eux qui nous le
disent il va avoir une date amélioration
dans les cinq jours qui viennent et
ensuite il faut toujours un petit peu de
temps pour redémarrer une raffinerie
c'est le cas de Gonfreville et je le
redis c'est spécifiquement sur l'essence
et c'est plutôt sur les petites stations
services j'ai changé avec la grande
distribution certaines
grands magasins nous disaient nous on a
aucun problème total a beaucoup moins de
rupture donc voilà c'est un sujet
dimanche d'ici la fin de la semaine je
l'espère et on a tout fait pour mais
aujourd'hui je dirais que la balle est
dans le camp des de ces entreprises
privées c'est leur métier de faire
fonctionner les stations l'État était en
soutien depuis maintenant trois semaines
je crois que c'est pas le travail des
préfets de mettre en relation des
stations services des distributeurs et
des transporteurs il faut que les
acteurs privés fassent leur travail et
redémarre correctement cette chaîne
d'approvisionnement ça veut dire un
dernier mot sur faisant puisque vous le
dites c'est le seul site qui est encore
en grève aujourd'hui est-ce que le
gouvernement va prendre des mesures pour
le débloquer pour le moment nous ne
prenons pas de réquisition dans les 48
heures mais vous le savez comme depuis
le début de la crise nous allons suivre
au plus près la situation pour faire en
sorte de soulager Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
et Bourgogne Franche-Comté un mot sur le
sujet des bassines puisque les sénateurs
ont interpellé la première ministre et
le gouvernement hier à de nombreuses
reprises est-ce que sur ce qui s'est
passé ce week-end à Sainte-Souline vous
aussi comme Gérald Darmanin vous
parleriez des causes terrorisme écoutez
moi je constate que il s'agit d'un
projet qui l'objet d'une large
concertation publique
sur lequel un consensus s'était dessiné
un consensus qui certes n'étaient pas
100% des positions exprimées mais enfin
très large que finalement c'est la
démocratie locale qui avait parlé et que
cette question ou cette décision est
remise en cause de manière violente par
certaines organisations ou
certains certaines personnes et quand je
dis de manière violente on a quand même
plus de 60
représentants des forces de l'ordre qui
ont été violemment attaqués et qui sont
violemment blessés donc c'est
inacceptable et je veux redire mon
soutien aux forces de l'ordre elles sont
là pour protéger les Français elles sont
là pour assurer notre sécurité il est
inadmissible qu'elle soit attaquée dans
ses circonstances à forti quand on
lisser la place à la concertation
publique quand toutes les opinions ont
pu s'exprimer et quand il apparaît que
élu locaux habitants
agriculteurs et je rappelle que les
agriculteurs ils sont ici pour nourrir
les Français ils sont pas c'est pas des
agriculteurs qui gardent ces taux pour
eux étaient d'accord entre eux pour
mener ce projet mais est-ce qu'on peut
mélanger écologie et terrorisme parce
que c'est ce qu'a fait Gérald Darmanin
en parlant d'écotérisme mais un moment
il faut être clair sur la situation vous
avez des personnes qui ont manifesté
contre la loi puisque cette
manifestation était interdite et elle
était interdite pour de bonnes raisons
puisque on craignait des problèmes
d'ordre public c'est très exactement ce
qui s'est passé et vous avez plus de 60
représentants des forces de l'ordre qui
sont aujourd'hui gravement blessés à
cause de cette manifestation donc il
faut nommer les choses et il faut dire
de manière claire la situation et les
militants qui demandent au gouvernement
de renoncer à ce projet vous envisagez
de renoncer pour vous il est hors de
question de renoncer à ce projet mais à
un moment il faut que la majorité des
personnes qui ont mené ce projet qui
sont d'accord sur ce projet ça s'appelle
la démocratie c'est-à-dire que quand
vous êtes en minorité sur un sujet vous
acceptez l'opinion la validation de la
majorité c'est le principe de la
démocratie revenir sur ça et inquiétant
et imaginez un seul instant que parce
que vous n'êtes pas d'accord que vous
êtes minoritaire vous faites un acte
violent ce serait un mode de régulation
de la société n'est pas acceptable c'est
ce qui s'est passé à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes où il y avait eu
on va faire un dôme local et le
gouvernement finalement renoncé à le
projet Bruno Retailleau dit que c'est le
gouvernement qui a donné un droit de
casser finalement qu'est-ce que vous
dites de ça je trouve que c'est un
propos politicien et qu'aujourd'hui les
positions du gouvernement elles ont été
exprimées par le ministère de le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
elles ont été exprimées nettement par la
première ministre elles ont été
exprimées une honnêtement par le
ministre de l'écologie Christophe Béchu
il n'y a aucune ambiguïté sur notre
position c'est c'est violences sont
inacceptables et moi j'attends que les
représentants de la République élu qui
sont chargés d'écrire la loi la respecte
et je trouve très étonnant que certains
se sont joints à ces manifestations
c'est à dire Yannick Jadot son vrai
nomson Yannick Jadot n'est pas élu
député cendrier des sauve des députés
européens nous avaient raison de le
souligner Sandrine Rousseau est député
elle écrit la loi elle a vocation à la
respecter c'est la moindre des choses on
va parler du texte développement
énergies renouvelable qui débute donc ce
matin avec un petit peu de retard dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat est-ce qu'un accord
vous semble possible avec le Sénat sur
ce texte
vous savez ça fait depuis le mois de
juillet que nous concertons très
largement avec les élus locaux les
associations d'éluge les opérateurs de
la filière les associations
environnementales et évidemment les
partenaires de tous les groupes tant
Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale et ce que
j'observe c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a
une véritable prise de conscience sur
l'urgence climatique d'une part et sur
la nécessité d'accélérer sur les
énergies renouvelables ce point n'est
pas contesté et de ce fait là je pense
qu'il y a un chemin possible alors il y
a la volonté aussi que les projets
d'énergie renouvelables
soit se développe de manière raisonnée
sur les territoires il y a la volonté
que les élus locaux puissent maîtriser
ce développement avoir le dernier mot et
cela nous convient parfaitement et on va
revenir dans le détail mais cet accord
vous le cherchez au prêtre qui est-ce
que vous le cherchez
possible sur la forme que pourrait
prendre ce droit de veto alors encore
une fois je vous le redis moi j'ai
travaillé beaucoup avec les associations
des lieux et les associations d'élus
eux-mêmes traces le chemin il disent au
fond il y a des choses qu'on ne demande
pas
un droit de veto d'emblée sur des
projets dont on n'a pas eu le temps de
prendre connaissance et sur qui serait
partagé entre nous le territoire qui
accueille le projet et les meilleurs
voisins n'est pas forcément ce qu'on
souhaite parce que c'est pas forcément
adapté à la position
de médiateurs que l'on veut adopter
c'est notamment l'Association des Maires
heureux de France qu'il signale
intercommunalité de France aussi a pris
position donc ils appellent plutôt à une
forme de planification
dans lequel il serait totalement parti
prenante qui leur permettrait de définir
des zones propices à l'accueil des
énergies renouvelables par rapport au
sein des documents de Scott et sur cette
base là de bénéficier d'un repousse de
l'État lorsque ils veulent avec des
porteurs de projets
implantés de nouvelles énergies
renouvelables ça peut se faire par
exemple au travers d'appel d'offres qui
recueillerait plus de soutien parce
qu'ils se positionne sur des zones sur
lesquelles les mers pensent qu'il est
nécessaire ou utile de développer des
énergies vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur la
montre mais est-ce que une fois que le
projet est ficelé est-ce que c'est aux
élus locaux d'avoir le dernier mot
est-ce que ça ça peut être envisageable
mais nous on respecte notamment ce qui a
été voté dans la loi 3DS qui donne le
dernier mot au maire sur des projets
d'éoliennes terrestres mais ce que nous
pensons c'est qu'il faut une
planification en amont définir des zones
propices aux énergies renouvelables que
ces zones propices correspondent à nos
besoins de production d'énergie propre
c'est essentiel c'est à dire ça doit pas
être juste à un carré de 10 mètres
carrés où on implanterait
trois panneaux photovoltaïques ça doit
correspondre aux besoins du territoire
et aux besoins du pays mais à la fin ce
sont les élus qui seront les partenaires
du développement des énergies
renouvelables et personnes d'autres donc
c'est clair c'est non à ce que demande
le Sénat sur le droit de veto l'objectif
de steak c'est aussi de faciliter
l'acceptation des éoliennes sur le
territoire pour cela vous voulez des
réductions de facteurs d'électricité
pour les habitants qui sont concernés
quels sont justement les habitants
concernés précisément à quelle distance
et quel sera le montant de ces
réductions alors sur ce sujet là nous
faisons une proposition je dirais que
c'est un article d'appel qui vise à
permettre au parlementaire de se
positionner et de faire des propositions
des propositions intéressantes sont
ressorties du premier travail en
commission développement durable
notamment le fait de pouvoir ouvrir le
capital des projets aux habitants et aux
élus enfin aux collectivités locales
je pense que c'est une très bonne idée
parce que ça permet au fond à chacun de
s'approprier ces énergies renouvelables
de les rendre plus désirable s'agissant
de la baisse de factures là aussi c'est
une proposition qu'on fait donc à un
moment il faut fixer une limite on a
proposé de le faire à 5 km autour de
l'installation mais là encore vous êtes
ouvert le gouvernement est parfaitement
ouvert au débat
d'autant plus que le Sénat au fond
reflète et porte la vision des
territoires que sur ce sujet là il peut
avoir un débat entre Région Département
intercommunal niveau intercommunal
niveau communal et que il y a plusieurs
façons aussi de partager la valeur des
installations d'énergie renouvelables ça
peut être
compléter les budgets qui sont consacrés
à des projets de transition énergétique
pour les collectivités locales au moment
où elles ont besoin d'investissement ils
ont besoin d'argent ça peut être baissé
la facture directement des habitants ça
peut être baisser la facture des
collectivités locales au fond je crois
que là aussi il faut qu'on travaille
ensemble et qu'on trouve le chemin mais
c'est surtout que le Sénat veut que
l'argent est au collectivité plus qu'aux
habitants est-ce que ça ça fait partie
des lignes rouges là aussi pour vous
est-ce que vous êtes ouvertes est-ce que
ça aille au collectif j'ai été très
clairement moi je suis ouverte à trouver
la meilleure solution qui rend les
énergies renouvelables plus désirable
sur le territoire
j'ai les mères qui me disent il faut
absolument que ça aille à mes habitants
parce que c'est le signal dont ils ont
besoin j'en ai d'autres qui me disent
non c'est important que ça vienne
nourrir des budgets de collectivité
locale mais on entend que c'est
peut-être important que ces budgets
soient orientés vers la transition
énergétique ou voir des ou sur des
projets qui font du sens et pas
nécessairement sur des projets qui n'ont
rien à voir avec la question de la
transition énergétique je suis à
l'écoute et on va construire ces
solutions ensemble les éoliennes qui
sont concentrés dans certaines régions
ça aussi ça joue sur la question de
l'acceptabilité des Français est-ce que
là vous allez prendre des mesures pour
qu'elles soient équitablement réparties
sur le territoire alors il y a deux
sujets sur ça c'est-à-dire que vous
n'allez pas implanter des éoliennes là
où le régime devant n'est pas favorable
donc c'est pas illogique que les
éoliennes se sont positionnés dans des
régions qui ont plus de capacités en
matière d'énergie d'origine dont le vent
est à l'origine ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est que vous
le savez dans la planification
énergétique que nous proposons l'idée
est de partir du potentiel de chaque
territoire et dans le potentiel de
chaque territoire il y a ce qui a déjà
été fait donc évidemment il faut prendre
en compte ce qu'il y a déjà été fait et
ne pas rajouter
des installations là où il y a déjà eu
un effort conséquent et puis il y a une
troisième chose c'est qu'on peut
travailler sur ce qu'on appelle
en mauvais français le ripowering
c'est-à-dire partir d'installation
existante et les rendre plus efficaces
et vous pouvez ainsi avoir plus de
potentiel de production d'énergie c'est
à dire avec le même nombre de ma pour
produire 25 à 30 % de plus d'électricité
tout simplement parce que en 20 ans les
technologies se sont fortement
améliorées et donc on peut produire plus
d'électricité avec le même nombre de ma
d'éoliennes ça peut être une solution
par exemple pour des territoires que je
connais bien comme le haut de France qui
accueille beaucoup 25% de la production
d'éoliennes en France ou Grand est un
amendement du Sénat elle a aussi ça fait
partie des points a priori bloquants dit
que les éoliennes en mer doivent être
positionnés à 40 km des côtes ça pour
vous c'est pas négociable ça c'est
surtout un sujet je dirais géographique
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui si vous
positionnez à 40 km des éoliennes en mer
des côtes ça veut dire que vous ne
pouvez plus utiliser la mer du Nord vous
ne pouvez plus utiliser la Manche et
vous ne pouvez pas utiliser la
Méditerranée pour différentes raisons la
Méditerranée c'est parce qu'il y a des
canyons profonds et donc en Méditerranée
vous ne pouvez pas installé aucune aucun
type d'éolienne aujourd'hui qui existe
même en termes de prototype donc ça
voudrait dire concentrer toutes les
installations d'éoliennes marines sur la
façade atlantique et ça voudrait dire
également
devoir différé de plusieurs années des
projets puisque la technologie qui
permet de mettre des éoliennes à 40 km
des côtes aujourd'hui elle n'existe pas
de manière industrielle on n'a aucun
parc d'éoliennes de 500 MW comme on le
fait 500 MW c'est la puissance d'une
d'un demi réacteur nucléaire n'existe
dans le monde et donc quelque part c'est
reculer pour mieux sauter et puis moi je
suis très inquiète du signal que ça
enverrait à la filière il se trouve que
cette filière industrielle est une des
meilleures du monde elle est en France
elle exporte aux États-Unis elle exporte
en Écosse c'est plus de 6500 emplois
directs notamment à Saint-Nazaire
pas Cherbourg et au Havre est-ce que
réellement on veut mettre un coup
d'arrêt à cette filière et
fragiliser ses emplois en envoyant le
signal aux opérateurs industriels que
pas de ça chez nous avant 2035 ou 2040
je crois que ça serait une décision très
profonde et donc il faut bien mesurer la
portée bon donc si on vous comprend bien
c'est non sur le droit de veto des mers
tel que écrit par le Sénat et sur les 40
km mais vous êtes plutôt ouverte sur la
question des collectivités et notamment
des bénéfices que pour étirer les
collectivités de cette chose sur le
droit de veto il y a plusieurs
formulations dans le texte donc nous
nous avons travaillé avec beaucoup de
sénateurs à avoir une formulation qui
permet effectivement au maire d'avoir le
dernier mot mais dans le cadre d'une
planification de l'énergie qui soit
ambitieuse un dernier mot sur ce texte
puisque le gouvernement n'a plus le
droit qu'à un 49-3 hors-tex budgétaire
est-ce qu'il est envisageable de
l'utiliser sur celui-là ou est-ce que
c'est non d'emblée ce sera sur un autre
texte ce n'est pas l'ordre du jour
aujourd'hui pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'encore une fois il n'y a aucune
raison que des groupes politiques qui
revendiquent de défendre la dépendance
énergétique de notre pays qui revendique
de lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et qui revendique de protéger
le pouvoir d'achat des Français et la
compétitivité des entreprises et donc de
leur donner accès à une énergie qui soit
accessible en prix votre contre ce texte
et donc je crois qu'il faut sortir de la
posture politique dans laquelle ils sont
quand vous les oppositions sont dans une
caution politicienne je crois que si on
devait pas trouver d'accord sur ce texte
sa témoignerait d'une posture politique
je veux prendre ici
les Français à témoins je vais appeler
les groupes politiques à la plus grande
vigilance la France est en retard en
matière de production énergie et en
particulier des énergies renouvelables
donc nous avons une responsabilité vous
le voyez nous avons concerté depuis
plusieurs mois de manière très ouverte
on n'a pas de ligne rouge qui soit
inatteignable et donc aujourd'hui nous
devons être capable ensemble de
construire ce consensus et j'observe que
cette position est assez largement
partagée dans plusieurs groupes avec
lesquels j'ai pu interagir ces derniers
jours cette volonté d'aboutir cette
volonté de donner enfin une indépendance
énergétique à notre pays un dernier mot
sur le nucléaire entre parenthèses mais
sénateurs et notamment de droite et
notamment Bruno Retailleau déplore
cueillait un projet de loi énergie
renouvelable un projet de loi nucléaire
il parle de textes à la découpe et il
déplore qui est pas de cas général
qu'est-ce que vous dites de ça je leur
dis qu'ils connaissent très bien
la politique énergétique portée par le
gouvernement puisque le président de la
République là très clairement
annoncé à Belfort en février dernier et
la première ministre apporté devant le
Sénat un débat sur la politique
énergétique du gouvernement il y a
seulement deux semaines donc ça c'est
connu et on a un calendrier qui est un
calendrier logique nous sommes en retard
sur les énergies renouvelables nous
n'avons pas fait notre
quantité de développement d'énergie
renouvelable on est le seul pays en
Europe à ne pas avoir déployé
suffisamment d'énergie renouvelables il
faut rattraper ce retard ça s'appelle
anticiper nous avons par ailleurs une
large concertation sur le mix
énergétique c'est la première fois que
nous ouvrons cette concertation aussi
largement au public je pense que c'est
normal c'est un sujet qui est essentiel
on sait qu'il y a du débat entre combien
consommer jusqu'où aller dans la
sobriété quelle part pour les énergies
renouvelables pour le nucléaire quelle
part pour les fossiles puisque l'enjeu
c'est de sortir des fossiles je veux
redire ici que deux tiers de nos
énergies sont fossiles et comment
financer ce débat il faut lui laisser le
temps de se dérouler il donnera lieu à
un projet en 2023 qui nous permettra de
remettre à jour notre programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie et l'ensemble des
parlementaires seront évidemment la
manœuvre pour amender pour corriger et
pour voter et justement parce qu'on
parle de remise à jour dernière question
de cette programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie il était envisager la
fermeture de 12 réacteurs d'ici 2035
est-ce que vous allez revenir là dessus
mais je crois que le Président de la
République a été très clair aussi sur ce
sujet là donc il n'y a aucune ambiguïté
sur la ligne du gouvernement la première
ministre là encore rappelé au Sénat au
moment du débat sur la politique
énergétique notre souhait notre
recommandation c'est de prolonger les
réacteurs aussi longtemps que les
conditions de sécurité le permettent ça
c'est clair mais donc pas de fermeture
des 12 réacteurs d'ici 2030 aussi
longtemps que les conditions de sécurité
le permettent à un moment je rappelle
qu'il y a une autorité indépendante qui
s'appelle l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
qui valide ou pas la prolongation de vie
des réacteurs n'oublions pas que
initialement nos réacteurs ont été
construits pour 40 ans et qu'il s'agit
là de prolonger leur vie au delà de 50
ans et donc c'est un sujet qui n'est pas
seulement un sujet de volonté politique
c'est aussi un sujet de sécurité
nucléaire et nous ne
plaisanterons pas avec la sécurité
nucléaire merci beaucoup merci Agnès et
on suivra bien évidemment le l'examen de
ce projet de loi sur le développement
des énergies renouvelables merci d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin on va
continuer
[Musique]